earlier this week there was a sort of
announcement about a bug in a program
called SCP SCP stands for secure copy
it's a way of copying files between two
different machines using SSH as a sort
of background transport protocol to make
the copy so it's a secure way of copying
a file from one remote machine to your
local machine or vice versa
personally I use it all the time to copy
files from my laptop to the desktop
machines particularly from outside the
office and so on it's a very easy way to
do things from the command line so he
talked about SCP the name of a machine
and then the file we want to copy so I
know it's stored at this location
remember name and so they want Corey to
the local machines I don't give a
machine name we're just in this case I'm
putting a full stop for the current
directory hit return ask me for my
password and it starts copying it in
this case it's going over to wireless
network so it's not going that fast but
it's copying it off this machine on here
and so we're copying that file from that
machine to here so the books that were
sort of disclosed by Harry Sentinel and
f-secure basically allow a malicious
server when you ask it to copy a file it
allows a malicious server to return
basically any file it likes to your
machine there are some limitations and
the client will happily write it into
the right thing even if it's not a file
it requested so I could say please
download our PI to our PI - image GZ
from my machine and the server could say
here here's dot bash profile and it
would copy that into the current
directory and if that was the my home
directory that would override my dot
bash profile which is a script that gets
run every time I log into the machine
and so the server would be able to pass
it down a file but the next time I
logged on would allow the malicious
actor who's taking control of the server
to sort of infect my machine with some
code that they wanted to run the way the
exploit works the server is able in
certain circumstances to not send down
the file that the user requested but to
send something else down and put it in a
way that and that it gets the client to
put it in a place where it could
potentially overwrite some files
they contain authorized keys that allow
you to log into the system or replace a
script that gets run a startup like your
batch profile
I mean actually this burg dates back way
before SCP existed because it's actually
come from an earlier program called RCP
which start was stood for remote copy
did pretty much the same thing but
unlike SCP it didn't bother encrypting
the data as it went over he just did a
straight transfer
this was written in 1983 it's part of
one of the early berkeley releases of
unix and there's been quite popular
until obviously SCP came along in the
mid 90s SCP takes the RTP protocol and
basically implements it exactly the same
but using a secure transport using ssh
to transfer the data the interesting
thing though is that both the way that
SCP and RCP work is I find a little bit
interesting and that when I ran this
command on my machine here SCP it
connected to the other machine but you
might think okay talk to the SSH daemon
on there the protis is a server on there
and says please send me this file but
somebody does if I run that program
again and I chose a file that was big
enough it would take a while to do that
I'm gripped to see what SCP is doing so
I'm looking all the processes and
particularly the ones that are SCP I
find the program I ran SCP jailer the
name of the machine to copy the file but
there's also this other one on the line
above and what's actually happening the
way SCP actually work because it makes a
standard SSH connection from my laptop
to the remote machine or whatever
machines are connecting and it runs the
SCP program on the remote machines with
a specific flag in this case it's minus
F and then the name of the file that you
want to copy and if we look on this
machine just to show the case then we
can see again that that program is
running on that machine so the way that
SCP works it connects to the remote
machine and runs SCP on there with a
flag telling it it's being run on the
remote machine and if you look in the
source code for SCP you can see how it
does that it detects that flag in it
then those it's going to send a file
back over and what SCP does
is it sends their over a little header
which describes the fire that's going to
send and then it just sends the data
over the standard output the UNIX
provides which gets routed over the SSH
connection back to the copy of SCP
you're running on machine which doesn't
writes it out the disk so let's have a
look at how that sends things and we can
do that because if we go back to where
we're transferring the file and stop it
we can actually ask SSH or SCP in this
case they give us more information about
what's going on and get it to print out
the message isn't is something between
thing give us debug information by using
the minus V flag so if we run SCP again
with minus V in there then we get all
sorts of information about the key
exchanges that are happening it's asking
me for my password again and then
eventually we get down here where it
says I'm sending the command that I want
to run so it sent the command SCP with
the minus three and the minus F flags
across that's now running on the other
machine we can see it running on there
and then it shows us the command that it
received from the copy of SCP running on
this thing so we got the line of text
capital C and then the permission bytes
for the file in this case 0 644 in octal
and standard UNIX permissions we've got
the size of the file in bytes three four
one zero seven nine one one more one in
this case a big file and then the file
name and then we can see it transferring
the file and occasionally as it's doing
that we'll see the keys get updated as
it changes encryption keys to make sure
that we don't lose anything the problem
is that this line here the ones preceded
sync the source code before the SCP
client just takes the filename that's
returned and uses that as the file it
writes to the disk
now just do some simple checks it checks
that you're not trying to traverse up
the directory structure it checks that
you haven't given it an absolute path
but other than that it just writes that
file to do so if you were to write a
malicious piece of software and all we
need to do is replace the SCP command on
the remote machine don't you do anything
more complicated than write a program
that returns the right values
to compromise the system and then
replace the SCP binary on that machine
we've got root access to that server
that would be relatively easy for us to
do so what we need to do is change the
value that gets sent back and then this
client because he doesn't check that
value is a what it asked for or B make
sense beyond some very very simple
checks we'll write that new file into
the current directory or if you've asked
for a recursive copy copy lots of files
in different directories it could write
them into other directories or it could
even change the permission on the
current directory so it could be used in
certain circumstances to enable people
who've got control of the server to push
files down onto your client when you use
that command I mean some ways this
functionality has to be there because we
specify our wild-card and you're copying
files you don't know what their names
are then the server has to be able to
drive the client what files is going to
send down otherwise you'd have to know
what the files are on the server before
you could copy them down I think the
real core the problem here is it's not
doing perhaps stringent enough checks
and that there are certain things that
you can send down for example it can
send down a line that forces the client
to change the permissions of the current
directory and it's just not doing quite
enough checks it's relatively simple to
fix making sure the checks on the
returned file make sense so for example
if we request in one file that we get
that one file if we were dressed it to
copy a directory that the files that
come down and inside that directory if
we requested a wild-card to select
multiple files that actually the file
names that it's sending to us matched
that one cause it's just a matter of
putting a few more stringent checks into
the actual program should we be worried
too much about this well there are other
things we can do for example we could
use SFTP rather than SCP to do that it
has been patched in certain versions of
OpenSSH now which will be coming out
soon certain variants of it's still
there and things like PS CP and winscp
on windows it has the potential if we're
not careful that you could do something
but I think there's another ways around
at the moment and something
we can patch the software and get around
it but it's interesting because it's
sort of the very simple file transfer
protocol that was developed for our CP
he was just copied straight over in the
mid-90s when SSH first came along and
he's been left there and these things
have been there for the past well 30 35
years I guess almost those six years
lying there in the various different
things but of course perhaps people
haven't tried to exploit them before now
I've got the token so I can lay the
value in AD the valley from emerged or
into it and store it back and hand the
target and now I've got the token again
I can load something into my register
the problem is that suppose we want to
do like a big Gaussian blur or really
large window this is going to get slow
really really quickly